[Music]
divinity original sin to continues to
deliver moment after moment of weight
you can do that so here are even more
tips to help you do some real weird and
wonderful stuff while you wonder through
Rivlin slipping on ice not only makes
you look like a complete fool but also
means you'll miss a valuable turning
combat a comment that dorky Darko left
on a last tips video points out that you
can combine a handful of nails to any
pair of boots to perma Lee add the
benefit of grip so now you can
confidently walk over sheets of ice
without the fear of falling on your god
woken ass it's a good idea to have your
party members carry a spare shield in
their backpacks just in case they need
an emergency top-up to their shields if
your abilities are on cooldown or you
need a boost in a pinch you can use one
action point to equip a shield two
action points to use the shields up
ability and then your last action point
to switch back to your main weapon now
this might cost you a turn but if it
means staying alive or taking some
damage away from one of your weak
characters to tank it onto you then it's
a turn well-spent
sneaky thief smug McMuffin correctly
points out that you can distract NPCs
while pickpocketing them it can be quite
frustrating trying to pilfer some goods
from someone's pouch when they keep
walking around or even turning around
and seeing you you can actually easily
remedy this by using one of your other
characters selects one of your other
party members and engage in dialogue and
talk nonsense - whatever NPC you want to
steal from this will keep the attention
away from your pickpocket ear and on
whoever's talking all the while your
thief is helping themselves to a
five-fingered discount
since I always made sure my characters
had as much weaponry as they could
handle I actually had no idea that this
was a thing but if one of your party
members has an empty hand they gain the
sucker-punch ability the damage on this
attack is actually pretty decent but the
main benefit is having the knockdown
ability using Sucker Punch you can knock
the enemy to the floor for one action
point letting yourself and the rest of
your party well on them for an extra
free turn so if you've got some extra
action points it might be worth
sheathing the sword and uppercutting a
fool instead there's a combination of
skills that's so powerful you can almost
call it overpowered so obviously we had
to add it to this list that is the
combination of the ruptured tendons
ability and the chicken claw ability a
great combination for anyone who's
playing as a scoundrel if you're not
familiar ruptured tendons will make a
character take damage for every step
they take and every move they make and
chicken claw turns them into you guessed
it a chicken funnily enough an animal
that knows how to do little other than
run around in circles
after afflicting these two status
effects on my enemies I'd often watch
their chicken selves just run themselves
into a death which was just oh so
morbidly satisfying
[Music]
after talking to a few people about the
game they expressed the desire to
respect their character
apparently missing what lies in the hull
of the lady vengeance at the end of the
first act when you're travelling across
the sea to Act two you may discover that
the ship you're traveling on houses a
magical mirror this mirror allows you
not only to change the appearance of
your characters but their attributes
abilities and talents as well so if you
want to full spec someone into law
master or feel like you can drop a few
Forness points you can get some extra
strength or even just remake your
character entirely that option is
completely open to you although you will
have to buy a new set of skill books if
you want to turn your tank Inquisitor
into a geomancer another cheeky little
advantage you can gain before a fight
breaks out is to bring in your summons
ahead of time once everyone has brought
forth whatever beast they have either
enter the zone of aggro or start the
conversation with whatever thug you had
a bad feeling about just in case they
turn nasty
the summons will get some free turns as
will the rest of your party enabling to
save the AP cost since they did it out
of combat as well as taking away some of
the enemy aggro from the guys you
actually care about and all while being
able to well and the bad guys right out
of the game now it's possible to double
your party size if everyone summons
something so this definitely stacks the
odds in your favor so make sure a few of
your guys have some summoning abilities
or the odds summoning scroll so those
were seven more tips that you can use to
your heart's content while playing
through divinity original sin - we
always love hearing the clever tips you
guys come up with as well as your
awesome divinity original sin to stories
so if you have any tips or tails then
leave them in the comments and for more
divinity original sin to stuff then make
sure you keep your eyes on GameSpot calm